E
NEXT JP MORGAN.
>> JP MORGAN OF THIS GENERATION.
SAM BANKMAN-FRIED.
>> WE TALK ABOUT HIM A LOT.
>> SAM BANKMAN-FRIED.
>> IS HE THE JAY COOL OF OUR ERA
OR JP MORGAN OF OUR ERA?
IS HE VANDERBILT.
>> HE COULD BE.
>> IS HE.
>> IS HE CARNEGIE?
>> Brian: OR IS HE THE BERNIE
MADOFF OR AL CAPONE?
WHAT ELSE IS THE MEDIA
HIGHLANDING FROM US.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO FIND OUT
NOW THAT THE ELECTION IS OVER.
BRING IN FORMER DEMOCRAT KEITH
ELLISON GABBARD.
FORMER PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
ALL THIS STUFF COMES OUT AFTER
PEOPLE VOTED?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, BRIAN, I WAS
READING THROUGH THESE ARTICLES,
AND THE THING THAT DAWNED ON ME,
IT REMINDED ME OF THE 8 YEARS
THAT I SERVED IN CONGRESS AND
HOW VERY QUICKLY AFTER GETTING
THERE I SAW HOW THIS PERMANENT
WASHINGTON ESTABLISHMENT IS A A
WHOLE WILL THE LIKE HIGH SCHOOL.
THERE IS A LOT OF IMMATURE
SELF-SERVING PEOPLE GOSSIPPING
AND CLICKS AND WHO IS GETTING
INVITED TO WHAT PARTY.
AND COOL KIDS SITTING IN ONE
AREA AND THE OUTCAST SITTING IN
ANOTHER.
AND, YET, THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO BE THE MOST
SERIOUS IN THIS COUNTRY MAKING
HEAVILY CONSEQUENTIAL DECISIONS
SAME THING ON THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN WHEN I RAN FOR
PRESIDENT ON THE DEBATE STAGE.
I WAS READY TO GO IN AND SPEAK
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT
OFFERING TO SERVE YOU AS YOUR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF AND YOUR
PRESIDENT.
HERE ARE THE SERIOUS ISSUES
FACING UP THE NEW COLD WAR AND
NUCLEAR ARMED RACE, NOBODY IN
THE MEDIA WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
THIS.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT NITPICKY
THINGS ONE CANDIDATE NOT WHAT'S
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, LIKE YOU SAID
EARLIER WHAT WE ARE SEEING OUT
HERE THEY FEEL.
THE MEDIA FEELS SO BETRAYED.
TO THE PARTY.
COZY RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN MEDIA
AND THESE POLITICIANS AND
BUREAUCRATS IN WASHINGTON.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S
INTERESTING?
THE CBS STORY IN PARTICULAR,
TULSI, THEY PRETEND THEY JUST
FOUND FORENSIC EXPERTS TO GO
THROUGH A LAPTOP THAT JUST HAD
YEARS OF PERSONAL PHOTOS AND
HORRIBLE PHOTOS AND HOOKERS AND
CRACK AND EMAILS, COULD HAVE
BEEN VERIFIED BY A PHONE CALL.
HEY, DEVON ARCHER, IS THAT YOUR
EMAIL TO HUNTER BIDEN?
BUT CBS NO INTEREST AND WE KNOW
WHAT SOCIAL MEDIA DID TO IT.
WITH YOU THEY ARE ABOUT TO BE
FOUND OUT.
SO THEY ARE TRYING TO GET AHEAD
OF THE STORY NOW THAT THE HOUSE
FLIPPED, ALMOST THE NEXT DAY
AFTER THE HOUSE FLIPPED THEY
PRETEND TO HAVE CYBER EXPERTS
DISCOVER THE LAPTOP IS REAL.
IS THAT OKAY WITH YOU?
IS IT OKAY WITH THE COUNTRY?
>> THIS SHOULD ANGER EVERY
AMERICAN BECAUSE IT IS
ABSOLUTELY REVEALING
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN JOURNALISTS
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING THEIR JOB
AND TELLING THE TRUTH REPORTING
FACTS RATHER THAN BEING
CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE PROTECTING THEIR
POLITICAL FRIEND, WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED HERE AND
THE LEAD UP TO THE 2020
ELECTION, ALL OF THESE PEOPLE IN
POLITICS AND THE MEDIA AND THE
NATIONAL SECURITY STATE AND BIG
TECH, THEY GOT WORRIED ABOUT
THIS LAPTOP BECAUSE THEY HAD A
FEELING IF VOTERS KNEW WHAT WAS
IN THERE, AND THEY MIGHT NOT
VOTE FOR JOE BIDEN SO THEY ALL
GOT TOGETHER AND SAID WELL, WE
HAVE GOT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO KEEP IT THIS FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEREFORE
DIRECTLY MANIPULATE AND
INFLUENCE THE VOTE -- THE
INFORMATION THAT VOTERS ARE
EXPOSED TO TO INFLUENCE AND
IMPACT THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION.
THAT IS THE REAL CORE ISSUE HERE
THAT EVERYONE SHOULD BE REALLY
DISTURBED ABOUT WITH THIS STUFF
THAT IS IN THE NEWS TODAY.
>> Brian: I HAVE A THEORY I WANT
TO SHARE IT WITH YOU.
DO YOU HAVE A MINUTE?
>> I DO.
>> Brian: OKAY.
THEY ARE DONE WITH JOE BIDEN.
AND NOW THAT THEY GOT THROUGH
THE MIDTERMS, HE IS 80 YEARS
OLD, THEY WANT TO MOVE ON.
SO THEY ARE NO LONGER GOING TO
PROTECT THE INFORMATION THAT
LAPTOP, WHICH DOESN'T SHOW A
PERSON ADDICTED TO DRUGS WHICH
SADLY WE ALL CAN RELATE TO
SOMEBODY IN OUR LIVES DIRECTLY
OR INDIRECTLY, IT'S GOING TO
SHOW A VICE PRESIDENT -- FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT DOING DEALS IN 50
COUNTRIES INCLUDING WITH OUR
ENEMIES THAT REALLY SOLD
INFLUENCE FOR 50 YEARS IN
WASHINGTON.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS GOING TO SHOW.
AND I DON'T THINK ANYONE IS
GOING TO PROTECT THEM ANYMORE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT
THEORY?
>> YOU MAY BE RIGHT.
THE YEARS I SPENT IN WASHINGTON.
SELF-SERVING.
LOOKING OUT FOR THEMSELVES.
NOT WANTING TO GET CAUGHT
LOOKING BAD OR NOT DOING THEIR
JOB AND LIKE YOU SAID, THEY ARE
SCRAMBLING NOW BECAUSE THE FACTS
ARE COMING OUT AND NOW THEY ARE
TRYING TO PRETEND NOW WE ARE
ACTUALLY GOING IT DO SOME
SERIOUS HARD HITTING REPORTING
WHEN REALLY TRANSPARENT ALL
ALONG, THEY ONLY CARE ABOUT
THEMSELVES.
>> SO GOOD YOU ARE A
CONTRIBUTOR.
YOU DI